going to lead off this morning with the
recipient last night of the inaugural
K&L gates professorship of ethics and
computational technologies Elinor Bosch
ela is the director of the community
robotics education and technology
empowerment lab for those of you who
were here last night you heard him refer
to the create lab now you know what the
acronym stands for which is focused on
the development of community-based
social and educational robotics and
really transforming people's lives
through community engagement to identify
the challenges that people face in their
lives and the ways that robotic and AI
technologies can really address respond
and spawned to those challenges and then
support people's abilities to achieve
their goals and over the years the
create labs programs have engaged over
40,000 people globally so the reach is
not simply here in the community not
simply on campus not even simply in the
United States but reaches around the
globe ILA's been a CMU faculty member
since 1997 is the author of four books
dozens of articles and holds 13 patents
some of which were part of what led him
to have a brief I believe career as a
startup entrepreneur he's been named a
Kavli fellow by the National Academy of
Sciences and in fact has been inducted
into the I want to make sure I get this
right the June Harless West Virginia
Hall of Fame so I think probably a
distinction that is unique in this room
following ILA's remarks he'll be joined
for a brief conversation by Tom Simon
Knight senior writer for Wired who was
previously the San Francisco bureau
chief at MIT Technology Review and has
written and edited technology coverage
at the New Scientist magazine and now in
his current position at Wired he covers
artificial intelligence and its effects
on the world without further ado Eleanor
Rosch
well thank you David for the wonderful
introduction and good morning all
to loosen my jaw and set the stage some
true stories first true story I'm
sitting in a room there's ministers of
Transportation and ministers of defense
ministers of sports from various
countries in the room and the
editor-in-chief of one of the biggest
journalism newspaper companies in the
world gets up and says we've been had by
ourselves when we published the first
story outing fake news I went online to
see our fake news story and on our
online version of our website there's
our fake news story in the middle and
above it and below it there was fake
news because we were selling Adwords and
the people who bought and won the
auction happened - the fake news
purveyors immediately and and he said
you know this is our own fault we don't
even know how to compensate our own
investigative journalism without being
part of a community that we're trying to
say is a disaster immediately gets up
the CEO of the biggest behavioral
analyst company in the world and says I
completely agree with that he just said
that was me I did the article on top and
I did the article on the bottom and
guess what I have a team of machine
learning people who are amazing at what
they do my computer's do hundreds of
millions of a/b comparisons a day and we
know this is a direct quote how to
maximize dopamine response by people and
we know how to make a system that
maximizes this and engages you and
causes you to click through and it makes
me money and I admit that it's not
completely ethical but it really works
well and I challenge any of you in this
room to come up with a better way for me
to make as much money and I'll switch
right away another story a few years ago
gentleman came back from war and started
a a bar Irish themed pub in Atlanta and
it was a transitional neighborhood where
gentrification was happening
but there were people homeless folks on
the sidewalk and he didn't like this
homeless presence on the sidewalk in
front of his pub so he built the world's
first bum bot bu m bo T robot controlled
by him that would threaten people on
this on the sidewalk with a
high-pressure water cannon and a
spotlight and a speaker and it made the
news stories and the stories in the news
which fascinated me were about the
empowerment he had as a maker inventing
a whole new innovative product now fast
forward about seven years last year
nightscope started having this wonderful
robot night scope which is a security
guard that you can rent and have roam
around your establishment night scope
was purchased by an establishment in San
Francisco because the sidewalk in front
of the establishment has so many
homeless people on it and so now we have
a commercial robot used by an
establishment to actually keep people
away from their sidewalk this is where
the story can't be made up it's too good
to be fake the establishment that bought
nightscope and used it to make sure
homeless didn't congregate on the
sidewalk in front of their establishment
was the Society for the Prevention of
Cruelty to Animals no kidding
go look this up so the SPCA used a robot
to intimidate people on the sidewalk
until by the way San Francisco City
Council made that illegal another one we
talked a great deal about war and robots
and whether robots should in a situation
where there's a war going on make
decisions about taking human life and
it's an excellent and important argument
to have and there's some outstanding
books on the subject
meanwhile in South Korea one of the
biggest electronics manufacturers in the
world made a machine gun activated
turret that's completely autonomous
users near-infrared to actually identify
people and shoot at them and it's used
today to guard some actual retail
establishments and it's already
installed today on the DMZ and it's not
one odd actor there are multiple
companies now doing this in South Korea
as well as in the Middle East
now go back a few years ago let's talk
about drones Los Angeles is testing
drones for one of the first times a few
years ago they had to join up in the sky
cameras down and the police were having
a blast flying this thing around just
like your kids except when they're
flying this thing around just playing
with it they noticed pot they noticed
the whole marijuana plantation behind
somebody's walls they went oh look at
that
what so they go in and make arrests and
it goes all the way up to the state
Supreme Court because the question is
they didn't have any right to search
they didn't have a warrant well what the
court said in the end was you know what
now that there are drones our assumption
to the right of privacy by having a high
wall around our house actually no longer
applies because drones are commonly
available and they go above things so
you don't get your right to privacy
assumed unless you happen to have a roof
over your marijuana plantation so it's
kind of fascinating that the legal
ramification was to change the rights we
have around privacy because of the piece
of technology that was boundary
technology and fast forward to a couple
months ago I was in a meeting with the
Minister of Transportation and where the
biggest countries in the world and we
were taking questions from the audience
about drones and people were saying
questions like well what's the
regulatory infrastructure you're gonna
put in place to allow drones to fly and
the answer from the minister was we have
no idea
somebody else has what about tort and
liability how we're gonna deal with
insurance around drones answer we have
no clue nearly every question the
audience asked the answer that was
received by the audience from the
Minister of Transportation for that
country was we have no idea okay one
final true story for you let's go to
cars
remember the cute Google car it had no
steering wheel you remember that it was
steering free why I think we need to
revisit that question because it is very
relevant to what you've been hearing
about in the news today so the reason
they had no steering wheel is kind of
interesting they took a bunch of pre I
Toyota Priuses and put the self-driving
software in it in early days we have to
give come up with some floral form for
it right and
then they trained Google employees to
use these cars and they put cameras in
them to watch the Google employees and
see what they do and the engineers then
reviewed the video footage of this and
they were gobsmacked there would be an
engineer who on their first day on the
highway from San Francisco down to
Mountain View or in the Google
self-driving car cameras there and their
babies in the backseat in a little car
seat and you know what they're doing
they're like this the entire time it's
so cute the whole time on the highway
there was one guy memorably who spilled
his coffee so for 10 minutes he was like
this on the floor trying to clean the
floor while the cars on the highway
barreling down the road so what did
Google do they had a meeting and they
panicked they said holy buckets people
who we trained who are Google engineers
carefully selected for their raw
intelligence of superiority are doing
what their completely trusting the car
well then the answer is obvious we had
to get rid of the steering wheel we
can't trust people at all that's why
there was no steering wheel in the
little cute Google car now fast forward
to the accidents you've heard about it
over the last few years dude in Tesla
watching Harry Potter am I getting this
right watching a Harry Potter movie or
listening to a Harry Potter audio drive
running into the side of a truck that if
he was looking up he would have seen
person in car running into a bicycle
where the safety driver is clearly not
paying attention for the couple of
seconds before the crash in a funny way
Google was right there attempted
solution was removing the steering wheel
a very extremely point of view the back
step was let's not bother with that
actual let's just leave it there and
make sure people know as Eric showed in
his video when people should just take
over like that as if people have the
sudden attention to jump into a
high-stress situation and react quickly
which by the way is the opposite of how
pilots work with auto pilots so what
wasn't in the news in that case is how
hard it is for all of these cars to see
bicycles but a human on a bicycle and
our nice thick legs make it obvious that
we are there but bicycles are a bunch of
little thin frames and the lighter goes
right through them and by the way all
those sensors the robots have are noisy
so when you have little frames
reflecting a little bit of light that's
noise if we were to actually see the
bicycles we'd be on a part of the curve
that Eric showed where we'd have a huge
number of false positives so we avoid
that by hoping to see their legs but
that means person walking with a bicycle
is walking with an invisible stick and
that's a problem so these are all true
examples and I want us to put on our
physicians hats and be a physician for a
second and say that these are symptoms
and the question I want to ask is what
are these the symptoms of and I have a
kind of hypothetical proposition for you
about what these are because I believe
these are all symptoms of one thing and
they're one odd thing that I don't think
we've spent enough time talking about I
believe these are symptoms of alienation
we're creating a world in which we are
alienating ourselves from the reality
we're constructing and there's three
ways in which I believe we're doing this
alienation I want to talk about that now
the first one relates to robotics itself
AI and robotics fundamentally was born
out of the desire to do
mimesis to mimic humanity it was all
about this question of what makes us
tick and how do we cognitively create
systems that tick the way we do how do
we replicate the human miracle in
machine form and that's mimesis it's a
one-to-one replacement of the human
intelligence with something new and
maybe that's why they called it AI which
I agree 100% with Eric is kind of a bad
name for it the word artificial throws
us off fundamentally the first form of
alienation I'm going to talk about is
the alienation from mimesis itself AI
the reality what it is today
has alienated us from that very idea of
a one-to-one relationship or one to one
replacement hypothesis from person to
artificial person we don't aren't making
artificial people by any stretch in fact
if I look at the most successful AI
systems today that I boast about and I
am proud of they have nothing to do with
they don't work like people they don't
smell like people they don't behave like
people but they solve world problems I'm
gonna give you two quick examples to
give you a sense of how different these
systems are how alienated from human
mimesis first system I love done by
Steve Smith right here in Carnegie
Mellon University East Liberty all the
traffic lights in this neighborhood have
cameras on them now and instead of
having regular metric counters that
decide how long the green light red
light episodes last these cameras look
at pedestrians and they look at cars and
they optimize beautifully across a
network of dozens of lights the exact
pacing of the red and green lights in
such a way as to minimize idle time in
cars and maximize pedestrian throughput
which you get is much much faster
pedestrian walking and much much less
particulate matter in the air from
idling it actually works something
extraordinary like I think 40 percent
reduction in local pollution just from
idling of cars I mean ridiculously cool
results but this is an intelligent
network of cameras responsive to people
and pedestrians is that a human is it
replacing a human job no it has nothing
to do with any task that a human had
been sitting there doing there are no
gnome is sitting there hitting lights
turning lights green and red this is a
whole new category of action I'll give
you one more example that comes out of
the old lab of Jeff Schneider and a
number of other people at Carnegie
Mellon which is the ability to do
behavioral analytics to discover
dangerous situations they did a very
famous piece of work about seven years
ago looking at purchasing habits in drug
stores and they were able to create
systems that can in advance predict the
onset of pandemics in the United States
like the cold virus by changes in
purchasing habits and drug stores
there was nobody doing that at the CDC
like that
because it couldn't be done it's a big
data analytics problem and they did it
and they took the same system and today
they use it for human sex trafficking so
they're able to actually find elements
of human sex trafficking around the
world by simply taking all of the
communication media in the internet and
analyzing them at massive speed that
does not replace anybody who's doing
that work that way instead
it's not mimesis but a whole new way of
thinking about computational
intelligence applied to a real problem
now the second problem the second kind
of alienation alienation from failure
and this is a really big problem we have
an intuition for how humans fail and
with natural intelligence we understand
what failure looks like and what success
looks like and I just explained to you
success does not look anything like
human success in the regime of robots
and AI but guess what failure looks
nothing like human failure either and
yet we have biases that make us try and
suit
the robot failure into the close of
human failure I'll give you a couple of
examples from two friends of mine Sewer
Russell has an example he uses he shows
a picture and in the picture there's
some people and there's a market and he
uses one of the online image analysis
tools and it spits out a sentence it
says a group of people buying vegetables
at a fruit stand and the people in the
onions look at this and go wow that's
awesome that AI system really knows
what's going on in that picture then you
zoom in on the picture there's no group
of people it's one person there's no
fruit stand it's a bunch of green leaves
and yet to you the human observer when
you look at that picture you'll love it
rod Brooks doesn't even better one he
shows a picture and the computer says a
group of children playing frisbee on
grass and then he asks the same system
because it is a good four children
playing frisbee on grass that one
actually gets it right so then he asked
the system so can six months olds play
frisbee it has no idea do frisbees taste
good no clue how far do fizz bees fly no
idea that sentence is there because a
statistical analysis that made that
sentence a construct associated with
that picture it doesn't mean that the
computer has any clue what any of the
individual words in the sentence mean or
what the semantics of that sentence are
in that particular case and maybe it
does and maybe it doesn't but we the
observers have no idea if it does or it
doesn't and yet our failing as humans is
to imbue upon that computer meaning
because it's using human language so
certainly it understands same problem I
have with my colleagues who put eyes and
ears and a smile on their robot and then
when it smiles you in view upon it at
effect when that effect is literally
Hollywood so that's the second kind of
failure alienation from failure the last
one is actually the worst one in a way
when I got my PhD we used to deal a lot
with something called non monotonic
reasoning humans make assumptions to
make the world something we can deal
with we ignore irrelevant detail and
think about relevant detail and then we
change our minds if something becomes
relevant that we thought was irrelevant
like oh my car is not starting and I'm
late for an appointment now I have to
start worrying about my car not starting
but I don't spend all morning worrying
about that until it becomes a real thing
so we sometimes call that things like
the closed world assumption we make an
assumption that the world is what it is
and it's kind of static until we have to
change our mind well the problem is we
make that assumption about technology
when I see the boundaries of efficacy
that a computer has I assume that's what
a computer can do that's what AI is
capable of and I will always be wrong
because AI is dynamic it is not static
and what it can do tomorrow is different
from what it can do today and our
ability as a human populace to make hay
of that does not exist we don't
understand how to think about a system
whose capabilities change every day and
that's a fundamental problem is that we
have a static model of a dynamic system
so diagnosis if we are being alienated
from this technology in the case of
success in the case of failure and by
our inability to understand how it's
moving what is the diagnosis well the
diagnosis is very simple where AI
illiterate and by we I don't mean the
wonderful lawmakers and colleagues that
I have in this room I mean the human
population I mean those who have to
engage in civic discourse nationally
internationally so we're a I literate
and it matters now compared to twenty
years ago because AI is actually
changing the world to its elections to
it marketing and all the other ways in
which a changes the world and it's funny
if you look at you know very very fast
financial trades they change the world
but at least in a little way we were all
read about it on marketplace the
difference is these new AI systems they
change what humans do on mass they
change our behavior so they're pushing
back hard I think the mistake got made a
few years ago when we invented the
phrase stem we really really missed
big time we invented the word stem we
said all our kids have to learn stem
stem is what matters and we excluded the
humanities completely when what ratters
is social science applied to the
computer science that we do it's the
combination of the two that lets us
understand the world and yet stem
excluded that divisive lis it also took
all of these disciplines and created
silos for them science technology
engineering math as if they're
individual areas of learning that we can
optimize and then we know what to do and
we don't because knowing anything about
those four alone and not
transdisciplinary doesn't allow us to
understand the changes in robotics so
I'm at the final part of my talk I've
told you about the problems the
questions what's our treatment and I
believe our treatment is actually that
we have to future-proof ourself to the
dynamism of AI itself we have to
future-proof our population to the idea
that artificial intelligence is a moving
entity and that it will change and I'll
give you an example Eric talked in his
keynote speech yesterday about not just
the fact that these systems have
computational bias but in fact
Microsoft's working on ways to overcome
that by us that's excellent but I
challenge you to show the fluency in the
public to then ask the next question
which is how will those corrective
techniques be tested and audited how
will we know if they work or not
how can the public know that they don't
have the literacy the fluency that we
need for that so fundamentally I think
we need the same kind of fluency for AI
for civic discourse that today we have
around say government people know how
the separation of power works in the
United States they know how elections
work they know what the electoral
college is everybody needs to have that
undergirding of knowledge so that we can
have civic discourse so we can make
decisions as a community we don't have
that undergirding of knowledge about AI
and that's a fundamental problem so in
conclusion what I'm saying is that we
need fluency and what that means is we
need to recombine a juxtaposition of AI
in humanity we need people to understand
what humanity is what are the ways in
which AI is actually what I'm gonna call
alien intelligence so I'll give you a
new moniker I'll keep the same acronym
to make it easy so there's
I'm gonna say it's alien intelligence
but I think we need the population to
understand how alien that intelligence
is how unrelated to the human form or
the human failings and I'm gonna give
you an example and pose you with a final
challenge the example I'll give you that
we've nailed recently is climate change
climate change is social and it's
systemic and what the world has managed
to do is come up with markers for
changes in climate the world has figured
out ways to systematize the
understanding of how climate change
affects the world both in terms of
access to clean water access to air
climate induced refugees political
changes due to climate and of course
nutritional gaps due to climate we know
how to visualize this we know how to
quantify this and because we can do all
that we can look 40 years hence show you
the ways in which boundaries are being
pushed in irreversible ways and as a
result what do we have we have the SDGs
the strategic development goes from a UN
we have very explicit and clear
boundaries along which governments can
actually act together because they can
see the possible future that's poor if
we don't do the right thing so that is
how we've dealt with climate change
there's a systematized approach that has
quantified the externalities of how
climate change affects humanity we need
this for AI if you take other ways in
which we've changed human behavior like
the opioid drug epidemic we're starting
to quantify that because it's having
such a massive impact on society like in
West Virginia where I do a great deal of
work but we need precisely this
quantified systematized understanding
for the externalities the ways in which
AI changes society so we can show the
boundary conditions and the knees and
the curves where we have to act as a
unified whole planet to enforce the
changes that cause us to stay within a
regime of controlled is acceptable that
means democracy that means personal
agency that means personal dignity and
my final point is mulready said AI is
dynamic fundamentally this means if we
don't do this if we don't create for AI
the same systematized approach with
essentially strategic goals as we have
for climate change we are otherwise
basically lobsters in a pod
warm water and the water will gradually
warm and will accommodate to those
changes ever so gradually and we will
change and by the time the water boils
we'll have changed quite thoroughly and
quite irreversibly thank you thank you
for a great thank you for a great talk
Gila let's sit down we have a few
minutes here so your talk reminded me of
something you said on stage yesterday at
one point you said that you were
convinced that artificial intelligence
would change our conception of humanity
and I wondered if you could expand on
that yes I think there's two things that
artificial intelligence does to us that
it's dangerous if it's doing it to us
and we're not recognizing that first of
all it changes our sense of what humans
are unique at and what we derive dignity
from the pleasure of dignity from
secondly artificial intelligence changes
our sense of what's possible
you know we're distracted so much by
stories of things like immortality and
the singularity precisely because they
redefine our sense of who we might be
one day I have had CEOs visit me here
who've popped a handful of pills during
lunch at Alibaba and I've jokingly asked
this one gentleman what are you doing
and he said oh I'm part of this life
extension program for immortality and he
was serious and when I jokingly asked
him so how do you deal with financial
planning for that hahaha he gave me the
card of his financial planner I said oh
I have a great guy and he does immortal
planning seriously that's the humanity
concept he has has completely changed
you know that's not a Bill Gates who
wants to think about his legacy in terms
of positive impact on the world that's
somebody who believes he's gonna live
forever and that's the world we now live
in is with people that have that mindset
and have levers of power okay and you
have worked with AI and robotics for a
long time and think about the
consequences has that changed your
understanding of humanity or your sense
of yourself I'm guessing you don't take
pills to your ever no I don't I think we
need to make room for the next
generation in general yes I think my own
sense
self has changed tremendously I think I
recognize that that we are less good at
understanding what we should be doing in
the world than we used to then I used to
believe I used to believe it was very
clear how we should have a quick career
and how we should kind of forge a
direction and have impact now what I see
is a world that's changing around us
quite rapidly and dramatically I
remember 20 30 years ago feeling like
the world's getting more peaceful
polaric polarizations decreasing things
are kind of looking good my kids are
gonna have a better life than me I don't
really feel that way anymore I feel like
we have a pathway that's rocky and we
have to do everything we can to keep
ourselves from actually ending up in a
words worse place than we are in today
right okay and you spoke at the end
there about trying to look to the future
and think about how am i changing what
it's being useful exercise and you
indeed write a whole book that kind of
see that approach robot futures in the
East chapter you you wrote a little
fictional skit looking ahead we were
talking about one of those earlier which
you title it mediocracy can you just
introduce us to that yeah there's one
that I called mediocracy the idea behind
that title was the story story with this
idea that a company has an inventory
excess inventory of 50,000 green lawn
chairs and the way you deal with that in
this conceptualized future twenty years
from now I didn't realize it was now is
you run your behavioral analytic system
create this book marketing copy for
every individual human being on earth
that maximizes the chance that they want
to buy a green lawn chair and you
overnight sell your inventory and it's
interesting cuz the tails backing you
the dog you're no longer building and
selling product that people need you're
simply controlling the need of people
with a giant universal remote to make
sure they buy whatever you have excess
inventory of and then the point I made
was that if we look not just at consumer
choice but voter choice what happens
when people are able to create highly
bespoke copy for each individual person
then maximizes the chance they vote for
the candidate who is paying the most
money for that marketing well this is
now happening I called it mediocracy
because at some point personal agency
has been reduced to the point where it's
hard
to any longer call the system democracy
it's difficult to use that word with a
straight face when in fact people's
political choices are not really being
controlled directly by their brain but
bias system that consists of their brain
and very carefully customized marketing
copy okay
so it's kind of it's an unequal fight
right you have this big analytic
machinery working against your you know
small biological system what what can we
do about that have you any thoughts
about how we can level the playing field
and allow us to continue to be you know
real actors in in reality I loved
Sunday's talks yesterday in his
spotlight speech I love the idea of
redress I think actually that's a really
important point I think the general data
privacy protection regulations that
Europe is putting in place or something
we should be emulating in the US I
believe we have to create really deep
understanding of the ethics of AI in
humanity basically from lower school
middle school high school all the way
through college so that the next
generation of engineers politicians and
civic leaders actually understand this
boundary technology and I think we need
disclosure you know the forms we signed
today the opt-ins are complete joke so I
think we need fundamentally to rethink
how we disclose the ways in which were
manipulated online the idea that the
biggest marketer can get up and actually
talk about dopamine in the in the view
of the public and not feel embarrassed
about doing that is remarkable that's
drug design it's exactly the same as
designing drugs for addiction and it's
become okay to talk about that right
okay and and you spoke about this this
failure of intuition that people tend to
have for artificial systems you know we
have a tendency to anthropomorphize and
project a little bit do you have an idea
of how we can change that Tennessee at a
large scale like can we maybe we just
haven't had enough time to learn an
intuition for how these machines operate
or fail as you might I actually think
that's something that's on some of you
the journalists and I think you can do
an outstanding job of that I believe you
know sometimes I talk and people say
well we can't make everybody a computer
scientists I think there's a huge
huge area in the middle between making
CBD computer scientists and leaving them
illiterate I think there's really
outstanding ways in which you can teach
people the teach people the failings of
these machines show them how the
computational bias for instance causes
errors in decision making and we can I
think teach a lot that stops far short
of having to force upon them getting a
PhD in the subject right so I think it's
education and I think it's investigative
journalism that can do that of course
the irony is we have rapidly falling
funding for investigative journalism so
instead we have people who don't get
monetized like the old Huffington Post
writers mmm okay and you also talked
about another failure you talked about
was this this failure from the Mises
field started out trying to do that and
and hasn't managed it can we get back to
it do we want to is it something that we
should desire it's an interesting
question you know I have colleagues who
are trying to make quite literally
babies the idea is if I make an
artificial baby then I can raise it and
it'll become human in ethical normative
behavior there's a whole hypothetical
there that people hew toward I don't
know in a value judgment sense that we
need to do mimesis I don't know that we
need to replace people one-to-one the
biological desire to understand how
humans work is is absolutely
outstandingly important and interesting
and we should always go toward that
cognitive orthotics will benefit from
that so our ability to help people have
quality of life as they grow old is
going to be directly impacted by our
ability to do that it's not so much that
the fact that hewed away from a basis is
bad as it is we have a tendency to
assume that that robot replaces a human
when in fact it's utterly alien to us
and unless we train people to understand
that I don't think they'll ever have the
the skin to accept that okay and we have
time for more question I'm gonna borrow
one from you yesterday on this stage you
said that everyone had to answer three
questions we have time for just one of
them so one of your questions was think
10 years into the future what is
something that you were very excited
about hey I'm making possible that would
would improve the world in some way
maybe you could take us out on a high
note in here that's a great question so
actually the quality of life of an
individual human is probably the thing
that I'm most excited about and so when
I look at everything from exoskeletal
structures that would allow somebody to
walk who were they to fall it would be a
huge change in quality of life but if
this system allows them to walk use
their musculature and if they start
falling it catches them you know I love
that idea I love the idea of extending
people's personal sense of agency and
empowerment and you can apply that in
this biological sense of you know
muscular exoskeletons and you can apply
this in a core cognitive orthotic sense
the idea that you can have cognitive
systems that work with a human not to
replace their thinking but to help them
keep thinking even as they're thinking
degrades I think is powerfully important
to our own ability to age gracefully and
aged well so to me that's the thing
where I believe those technologies based
on the cognitive side and on the
muscular skeletal side actually will
come of age in the next 10 to 15 years
and it's a sea change right I could go
for a walk with my great-grandfather a
hike up a trail at Yosemite which would
be unthinkable today and that I think is
very inspiring wonderful
ok the nice thing about the positive ELA
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]